i talked to you recently on the podcast
uh
i have a little side gig conor bryan
needs a friend people love your episode
you were hilarious
and that's when i said i got to talk to
this man some more i'll get him on the
tv show
but um we got into it a little bit you
got upset with me
because you said that i um
i smeared the image of one of your
favorite irish poets
not only from not only for the public
but it also ruined it for me which is
what really hurts
which is yates william butler yates
basically a saint of ireland
you know what i mean great one of the
great probably the greatest irish poet
and this mystic figure you know that you
always think is above
worldly concerns and then you point out
that he was like
getting some kind of like old-timey
erectile dysfunction uh techniques it's
true yeah that's true
i pointed out to you all i did was give
you a little history lesson and i said
that yates
later in life uh was concerned about his
ability to perform in the bedroom so at
the time in the 1930s there was a quack
doctor who was saying i'll inject you
with monkey glands the glands that have
ground up monkey glands into your
testicles
and it will help you it was the viagra
of its day only it didn't work
it was even worse because the way it
started was me going
one thing about the irish and yates they
age gracefully
like we don't mind getting old and then
you brought that up and it just
shattered my
illusions about yates well you know i
could make it up to you by
reciting some yates for you maybe
that'll do it you know
maybe you'd like that would you like
that joy would i will arise and go now
and go to innisfree and a log cabin
build there of clay and waffles made
nine bean rose will i plant there and a
hive for the honeybee
i like that that's a guy who's high on
monkey glands
that is a guy who was this rejoice he
was
so jacked up on uh ape glands
injected into his testicles that he
wrote that poem that's probably how he
recited it
probably how he did recite it you're
right and he was completely iraq to the
entire time
oh sorry hope sorry to ruin all the
poets for you
well next time i'll tell you what joyce
was injected with